welcome back to New Rock starss I'm Eric
Boss and this is a super cut chronology
of everything I have ever said about
Mesto on new rock stars through the end
of 2023 we thought we'd do something
special and share with you all of the
receipts every stop on the Mesto train
that got punched by a guy on the train
that you look up and it's not Tom Hanks
on the Polar Express it's the devil yes
if you watch this channel you know I
have been known as the guy who predicted
that misto would show up in W division
which did not happen and recently
according to W division director Matt
shackman was never in the plans for the
show now I'm not the only person online
who was misled by the numerous devil
Easter eggs in the series or by the
repeated statements by the cast that a
big Cameo was coming but you know after
W division episode 7 revealed that it
was AGA all along and most others caved
and gave up that Mesto dream I
stubbornly refused to get off the Mesto
train and still by the end of episode 8
thought that the guy was going to show
up in the finale and I was completely
wrong now I have said before that I was
pretty overwhelmed by the new attention
that new rock was getting at that time
nearly 3 years ago as everyone was just
excited to have new content again during
Co and despite being wrong about Mesto I
look back at Mesto as one of the best
things that has happened to me as a
YouTuber who analyzes Marvel anyone who
thinks that this is like a point of
Shame for me doesn't get it I'm grateful
for Mesto he taught me so much he made
me better at my job he gave me a sharper
Instinct for implausibility he taught me
the importance of crafting theories in a
way that doesn't alienate people for not
wholesale buying speculation my only
regret about all this is that I think a
lot of others misunderstood our
Channel's Mesto speculation and took it
as a kind of License to get more
aggressive with fan speculation getting
really defensive about it I don't know
it was probably naive of me I I guess I
kind of thought everyone would join new
rock stars in our perennial what we got
wrong tradition but looking around no
one else does that which is a shame I
don't know what it is about social media
that makes people afraid to admit when
they got something wrong so I'll admit
that in some way Mesto did ruin talking
about theories on social media and I'm
sorry for anything I did to contribute
to that but I think we forget that the
fun about theorizing about misto was
this kind of sense that something was
really disturbing at work week to week
in W division it's something that you
don't get when you binge watch a show
it's something you don't get when you
just like watch stuff in isolation and
think it only applies to you and your
brain it's like a communal ritual and
it's the kind of feeling I think best
appreciated if you were like me and you
watched lost week to week in the late a
of a certain age just learned from that
experience that it's okay to just like
let things go and appreciate the friends
that you made along the way now it has
been confirmed that Sasha Baron Cohen is
going to be playing Mesto in the Iron
Heart series if that ever comes but here
at the end of 2023 while I am out on
paternity leave being a grown up with a
newborn to take care of no we did not
name them Mesto please enjoy your
holiday season with a compilation of
every Mesto sighting on new rock stars
to now and you don't even have to watch
it in slow motion to hear the train go
off the rails and to see my heartbreak
and and to see the healing on the other
side of it enjoy and happy holidays
notice the old school file that Fury
gives cap there's some barely readable
texts at the bottom mentioning Mephisto
and infinity gems so Marvel released a
redacted version of this but the text
doesn't really match what's in the movie
Mephisto is Marvel's devil figure and in
The Infinity Gauntlet Comics he is right
at thanos's side as he collects the
infinity gems this paragraph looks to me
like an alternate backstory that Marvel
was considering for the infinity Saga
storyline eony ma says my humble
personage bows before your grandar yeah
we get it he's a boss but he's actually
directly quoting Mephisto thanos's
right-hand demon in The Infinity
Gauntlet Comics he has yet to make an
appearance in the MCU other than a
barely readable line back in Avengers
the reports of Evan Peters mystery role
in W Vision appeared amidst the news of
production for the series resuming in
July principal production took place
from December of last year through
February with a rap party on March 1st
but it looks like some re- shoots will
be needed if the original plan was for w
division to establish misto just to set
him up as the principal villain of
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness these W division re- shoots and
sudden announcement of Evan Peters in a
mystery role May indicate a shifting
back of misto from a mere post-edit
cameo in W division to be more deeply
entwined in the plot of the W Division
Series misto was hidden as an Easter egg
way back in 2012 in the first Avengers
film on that file Nick Fury gave the cap
about the tesser ACT there is one
paragraph that you can barely see
mentioning mephisto's name and in a
digital version of that record released
by Marvel Studios this paragraph Was
redacted but you can piece together the
original text to read how they want to
be used and deny certain wishes misto
has proposed that a billion sentient
universally linked will could overcome
this problem and that the cubes could be
as powerful as the infinity gems grammar
issues there but who's really looking at
it that closely in retrospect this looks
like a piece of Jos Sweden's alternate
backstory for the the infinity gems in
the MCU before Kevin feige and his team
retconed the Tesseract as the
containment for an infinity stone moves
that were made in later Phase 2 films in
the original Infinity Gauntlet storyline
Thanos is accompanied by Mesto who was
swapped out for his right-hand man ebony
ma in Infinity War ma even steals M
Fisto's line my humble
personage bows before your grander you
st my bit you that's my B but how will
Mesto tie in with one the maximoff story
and why specifically did they choose an
actor known for playing Wanda's brother
in an alternate movie Universe to play
Mesto okay misto is known as the
deceitful demonic dealmaker to
characters like Doctor Strange Silver
Surfer Ghost Rider but in certain comic
story lines he has shown up with Scarlet
Witch and vision one Envision be
children William and Thomas but the kids
keep Vanishing and reappearing because
we learn Wanda manifested them via magic
and they just go poof whenever she stops
thinking about them but later on Visto
reveals these kids to be fragments of
his soul and the witch Agatha harness
helps erase Wanda's memory of ever
having these kids now later on Wanda's
children return is a plot point of House
of M the huge Scarlet Witch event that
many of us assume will be an influence
for Wanda Vision in House of M Wanda
chaotically resets reality and attempt
to be with her hypothetical children it
ends with her erasing most of the
mutants from existence later on these
two kids get reborn as the mutants Billy
Kaplan Wiccan and Tommy Shephard speed
now in in this Wanda Vision series we
know these two kids must factor into the
plot the flickering sitcom realities
show Wanda and vision as parents to twin
babies and we see her in a kitchen with
fridge artwork showing the letters b
probably for Billy and T for Tommy one
of our recent big question episodes
explored the real world ramifications of
the snap and the blip including the
super uncomfortable thought experiment
of what would happen to pregnant women
in such a scenario I don't like to think
about this but just go with me on it
what if Wanda and vision from from their
opening bedside moments of infinity War
were with
child yeah what if she was pregnant that
Cosmic dusting and UND dusting could not
have been very good for prenatal health
so what if those babies did not come
back with her their souls snatched into
the void Beyond reality that would
definitely reframe Wanda's rage against
Thanos you took everything from me
everything good God so imagine Wanda
Vision as Wanda's desperate attempt Ms
to reset her reality over and over to
try to find an existence in which she
can live on Happily with vision and
their kids all together as a family it
could be a wish fulfillment spell
suggested to her by that nosy neighbor
character played by actress Katherine
Han many have suspected she will be
Agatha Harkness but Agatha's friendship
is actually two-faced because that witch
next door actually serves a different
Master Mephisto played by that devilish
star of American Horror Story Evan
Peters it was Mephisto who stole the
souls of Billy and Tommy but he did it
because he really wants the soul of
Wanda maximoff but again why hav't
Peters in this role well as we learn in
Bible School the devil takes many forms
and perhaps this devil will in his
effort to deceive and manipulate Wanda
briefly take the form of a version of
her dead brother Petro maximoff much
like that devilish god of Mischief shape
shifting into Captain America in the
dark world or the devilish ego shape
shifting into David Hasselhoff it could
just be a wink of a cameo of Evan
Peter's alternate Quicksilver as he
whispers to Wanda I can give you
everything that was taken from you like
your brother and she's like that's not
my brother and he's like yeah you try
shape shifting those traps Wanda's
challenge in Wanda Vision could be to
overcome these demonic forces and use
her own reality warping sorcery to
conceive herself in a new alternate
universe perhaps by letting go of vision
but holding on to Billy and Tommy in a
new reality a revised MCU with mutants
uh just got to pencil in a little r ey
there there you go no comma more mutants
Monica looks like she is exactly where
she wants to be and that's why I think
there is something to this idea that
this version of Monica could be an
impostor in Disguise as Monica not a
scroll Shape Shifter well maybe actually
I should come back to that but we should
first consider that Monica 2 could
actually be a disguise warn by mefisto
now yes you might be thinking why does
this dude keep bringing up misto there
have been literally zero misto anywhere
in this one division footage well in the
language of our new favorite House of M
wine bottle label Al contr just as the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world that Kevin spacy
was a good guy evil incarnate takes many
forms my friends Pennywise and it was a
shape shifter Bible stories and myths
have depicted the devil as a pig a goat
Elizabeth Hurley in this case I believe
Marvel's devil mytho as he is in the
comics that W vision is probably partly
based on is deeply involved in a plot to
manipulate Wanda with illusions of her
children and he is hiding in plain sight
elsewhere in this trailer so to
understand where Mesto is hiding in this
Wanda Vision trailer we have to first
try to understand how Wanda's pocket
Universe Works in the Scarlet Witch
House of M Story another possible Comics
influence on Wanda Vision Wanda warps
all of reality into El worlds to try to
give herself a happy family life but
here Wanda's reality warping appears to
be confined to this small town at least
a few Acres maybe a square mile which
could be an actual housing subdivision
or a rural clearing in a part of Upstate
New York that looks a lot like Georgia
because that's where they shoot
everything within this pocket Universe
everyone in it seems to be equally
oblivious to its true nature in some
moments though in other moments they
find themselves Awakening from a kind of
Trance we see this with Wanda and vision
when their dinner guests question them
about their backgrounds and there's
definitely a confusion with vision as he
tries to get a bird's eye view of the
town and when he Taps Agatha's head
am I dead
no why would you think that because you
are AG the believed Vision to be dead
suggesting that like those kids in
Midtown high school and far from home
she also comes from a post-endgame world
where vision is dead from outside the
pocket reality intruding into it judging
from vision's confusion I assume he also
started as an outsider but was brought
into this reality Agatha's right vision
is dead we all saw it and we did
actually go into a few explanations for
how he could have been resurrected
another video be sure to check it out
it's a good one but notice the Mind
stone is back in his head here and that
should not be possible Thanos atomized
the Infinity Stones at the top of
endgame where are the stones
gone reduce the atoms and the past
version of the Mind stone that they used
to defeat him was return back in time
pretty much everyone at Marvel has made
it clear that they're done with using
the Infinity Stones as plot points
themselves and no matter what
hypothetical timelines in the Multiverse
the mindstone could have existed in all
those timelines either would have ended
with Thanos getting the mindstone at the
cost of vision's life or in that one
Thanos less timeline that we've talked
about before the mindstone could have
lived on in vision's head but without
Thanos he wouldn't have died so yes
impossible right well assuming vision is
an outside body to this pocket reality
that has been warped into Wanda's
projected fantasy the same way Agatha
has been means some form of vision must
have been brought into this reality from
the outside the outside where he's dead
perhaps vision's Android corpse
recovered from wakanda brought into this
pocket Universe by Monica and sword and
then warped by Wanda's chaos magic to be
reanimated with the projection of the
mindstone in his head once more so I'm
thinking that's the process outside
entities intrude into Wanda's warped
bubble where she colors them as part of
that illusion Monica Rambo in Sword
perhaps used vision's body in hopes to
re in Wanda's reality warping to contain
it from spread spreading all over the
world but other Intruders like Agatha
have a darker agenda to trick Wanda with
the promise of having children with
vision while hijacking Wanda's chaos
magic to spill that chaos all over the
outside world this is essentially what
Mephisto aims to do in the comics and
Agatha serves Mesto and I think we see
the start of that plot in the trailer
where did you two move from how long
have you been married and why don't you
have children yet our story I think what
my wife means to say is that we moved
from moved from where married when damn
it why oh Arthur stop it stop it stop it
stop it Fred malamed here is playing
Arthur Deborah Joe rep plays his wife
they appear to be some neighbor couple
joining Wanda in vision for dinner but
they are so damn pushy the way Arthur
Badgers Wanda about having kids it's
freaking terrifying satanic some might
say yeah I believe Arthur here is really
a shape-shifted form of Mephisto
intensely pressuring Wanda to have
children children that he can use to
distract and manipulate her rups
character I believe is an incarnation of
Agatha who is subservient to Mesto
working with him trying to temper his
more violent tendencies misto comes from
Marvel's underworld and perhaps it was
Agatha encouraging Wanda's deeper
exploration of her inner chaos magic
magic that was imbued in her as a baby
by an ancient demon that opened this
Gateway into Wanda's pocket universe for
Mesto to sneak in through these false
forms and I think this evil duo will
continue to appear in new forms in each
of Wanda's new warps Agatha becomes the
Kimmy Gibbler to this Full House reality
maybe Mesto becomes a dummy with a
traffic cone hat until eventually Mesto
tricks Wanda with a form that she will
recognize as fictitious the sword agent
who escorted Vision into this pocket
reality Monica Rambo and this form Wanda
will expel from this bubble back into
the real world where misto plant will be
achieved because now he can walk the
earth freely now would misto have
counted on the op source of his flesh
mask being there the moment he broke
into the Earth Dimension doubtful but
I'm eager to see what kind of Hellfire
misto as Monica is about to drop on
these sword agents and in the House of M
Comics a heartbroken Wanda tries to
reset reality into a world where she has
a happy family here Wanda is warping
reality so that vision is alive once
more but her reality warping appears to
be contained with in this small town in
which I believe she is actually being
manipulated by nefarious entities the
witch Agatha working on behalf of
Marvel's devil mefisto the two of them
trapping Wanda inside her own dream
bubble that's really a portal to hell I
believe Agatha is brainwashing Wanda in
this illusion using TV sitcom reference
points to try to keep Wanda's mind calm
and vulnerable this whole 50s setting
with vision evokes the 2015 Tom King
Vision series which reconc Vision in a
similar atomic age now Wanda's sorcery
powers in the comics all come from her
being marked by the elder god Chon when
she was a baby which allowed her to be
able to use manipulate what's called
chaos magic I think the chaos magic is
what Agatha and misto want notice vision
and want's license plate reads 0102
maybe not to Avengers Issue 102 in the
70s when vision gets an offer from the
Grim Reaper to have his Consciousness
transferred to the body of Wonderman so
that Vision could be Clos to his love
Scarlet Witch but in this show I believe
Wanda has made a similar deal with the
devil metho to get Vision back in her
life and it is Agatha who helps Wanda
Manifest this happy home reality via
chaos magic but probably has plans to
hijack that magic for a darker
agenda am I dead no why would you think
that because you
are interesting so notice that single
tear that drops out of Agatha's eye the
moment Vision touches her as if
Awakening her from a trance to me this
suggests that Agatha herself is part of
this manipulation rather than the sole
orchestrator of it I don't think she's
the only antagonist here so I'm thinking
she's in a trance as a vessel maybe a
surrogate for mephesto in the comics
Wanda's children do start out as pieces
of mephisto's soul that mephesto and
Agatha used to manipulate Wanda and then
sadly those kids are like reabsorbed
into his soul before they're later
reborn as WIC and speed because Comics
also this might be nothing but our
friend alesio on Twitter pointed out
that the Italian translation of this
moment in the trailer Agatha's line
because you are dead the version of you
that they use is plural as if Agatha is
suggesting both vision and maybe Wanda
are dead that's why I think this pocket
reality is actually a hellmouth a portal
to the Marvel underworld where Wanda has
offered to trade her soul so that she
can be with vision and their kids a deep
deal with misto through his surrogate
Agatha making both Wanda and vision in a
way dead Katherine Han plays Agnes a
name I have speculated could be an
amalgamation of Agatha and Harkness
Agatha Harkness being the witch neighbor
from the Marvel Comics that I suspect
this series is based on in which AG the
Harkness is a servant of misto posing as
a friend and Confidant to Wanda with her
children but those children are really
just puppets used by Mesto to try to
take over her notice how Agnes here has
this pendant and no matter how much this
which's costume changes through the
decades that pendant is always there I
suspect this necklace may be connected
to her link to Mesto maybe even contain
mephisto's presence now her fingers
cover another headline the most
something home furnishes I think that
covered word is devilish with legs McGee
over there being either Wanda herself or
Agnes thus that devil red color another
clue that this home is being furnished
by Marvel's Devil Himself myth
then a shot of Agnes riding a bike with
a
basket style and then she gives Vision a
wink as we meet her companion a new guy
we have not seen before and like that
other husband Arthur Hart in the first
trailer I do think it is possible that
all of these husband figures could be
shapes shifted forms of misto I know
what you're saying God this idiot thinks
everything is meiso just think of me as
water boy Cathy Bates everything's a
devil everything is the devil to you
Mama W can you leave me who's doing this
to this sounds like the voice of agent
Jimmy woo and this is further proof that
Wanda is not in control of whatever is
happening that some other dark force is
hijacking her mind and her reality
warping powers and I think we see that
dark force in the next shot the mystery
beekeeper even Under The netting this
person's face is totally blacked out my
theory is well go with me my Buzzy Bees
this pocket reality is a kind of Hive
Wanda is its queen bee she is the
homecoming queen of the monkey song the
queen thinks she is Master of the house
but looking down from above is actually
The Beekeeper who is actually exploiting
this queen and her drones and her
workers to make products for him to take
and feed on her workers vision and Agnes
her drones these other figures that she
blasts out of the hive to pollinate the
world and the Honey is wand's chaos
magic unique to her and The Beekeeper is
you know Mesto hey I'll also give you a
nightmare but I'm pretty sure it's Mesto
we just saw misto in the Loki trailer
he's coming tricking Wanda into thinking
she has this beautiful home life when
really his goal is to drain her of her
magic
drain it there is another shot of Wanda
Envision looking out at what we assume
to be the static border of this pocket
reality and if you look very closely a
shadowy figure barely visible in that
static this figure appears to have a
kind of Cape not unlike The Capes worn
by people like misto or Nightmare and
then Agnes frantically asks why you here
to help us Jus in she too has no idea
why she's trapped in this conspiracy
bubble though it could be an act from a
duplicitous Confidant and we meet Agnes
a name we suspect could be derived from
Agatha Harkness the witch companion to
Wanda who secretly serves misto
Katherine hans's delivery is so specific
it's hard not to see every single one of
her lines and gestures as containing
some hidden double meaning Wanda Charmed
Charmed as in Charmed under a witch's
spell perhaps and then there's her
husband Ralph that she keeps bringing up
the only way Ralph would remember our
anniversary is if there was a beer named
June 2nd not that Ralph ever wants eat
anything other than baked beans are you
sure you don't want an audience
volunteer named my husband Ralph yeah no
one asked about your husband Ralph Agnes
so I assume he is either a corpse or
never existed or her pet name for misto
or somehow all three at the planning
meeting H you might have caught this
little gy the devil's in the details B
that's not the only place he is H
I have been betting for months now that
this series will introduce Marvel's
devil misto whom Agatha serves in the
comics that's who we think Agnes is
based on so really any mentions of
devils or satanic elements we are going
to need to highlight now sure you could
read this as just Agnes Throwing Shade
at doy or even hinting about the booze
she was about to whip out but then why
would Wanda wave her away as if she
already knew what Agnes was referring to
before seen the flask yeah Agnes is
hiding a lot and she's thirsty in all
kinds of ways she shows up at suspicious
times and she is now talking about the
devil hiding in places it's coming
together folks Agnes once again has her
pendant which appears to show three
figures some are saying this could be
connected to the three witches of MCB
Beth I'm not sure though there's
definitely a taller one that holds
something above these two smaller ones
maybe a clue that Wanda's children are
being kind of marionetta by another
entity actually pulling the strings
isn't it suspicious that FBI agent Jimmy
woo lost someone in federal w protection
someone whose past Associates claim not
to know suddenly and now Hayward is
throwing his All-Star agent Monica Rambo
at this I'm beginning to think Hayward
could have set all this up like he might
have made a deal with a devil that
mystery missing persons that Jimmy woo
was looking for whom I think could be
Agnes's Ralph and Hayward did this to
raise his status at sword while helping
that Kaiser so slip through the cracks
to hijack an unstable infinity stone
radiated Avenger to create a pocket
reality where she could resurrect her
corpse Boo and make babies all while
that devil figure drains her of her
power but now it has blown up in
hayward's face and he doesn't know what
to do now Petro's return could be
something as simple as a sweet gesture
from the boys trying to cheer up mommy
with a long lost brother that she said
that she missed but I don't trust this
guy he talks about squeezing his sister
to death he calls Vision a popsicle
which feels like a slur the way he says
it but guys guys guys the creepiest
detail is the mirror behind Wanda look
at it the second Petro comes in through
the door it's really hard to see but
this mirror looks distorted warped it
almost looks like Petra's hand is red
and I might be crazy but there's some
weird blur in this almost as if there's
some Thin gray arm reaching out toward
Petro beckoning him into this house what
is this reflecting there's nothing there
but there's something in the mirror look
whatever Petro's origin folks there's
enough in this to see him as a threat to
Wanda some kind of trick to give her the
one more thing she could possibly want
but like everything else in West View it
ain't going to last so then they go
trick- or-treating unleash hell demon
spawn whoa unleash hell demon spawn you
know I keep bringing up Maisto but this
is why in the comics Wanda's children
are actually revealed to be pieces of
mephisto's Soul demon spawn and as I've
been saying these past seven days since
finding that gray corpse arm in the
mirror this ain't Petro this is an
impostor wearing a Petro Halloween
costume just with a bit of stunt casting
by Marvel using a Quicksilver from a
separate film franchise W division might
give us a Multiverse might give us
mutants but this guy is a red herring a
pickled red herring and now this Mesto
has come to reclaim these children born
with Wanda's magic so he can reap the
benefits and he's doing it by wearing
the disguise of Wanda's dead brother
then Petro kind of explains how he got
here I got shot like a chump in the
street for no reason at all and next
thing I know I heard you calling me yeah
he's really kind of making fun of his
own death and Age of Ultron suggesting
this Evan Peters Petro is not the
Quicksilver from the fox X-Men movies
who would not know what Aaron Taylor
Johnson Petro's dying moments looked
like but rather this might be someone
from this universe or Beyond this
universe who saw that death but it's now
okay with mocking that heroic
significance who does that sound like to
you notice how she clutches her chest
she feels around that's because she's
looking for her brooch if she is a witch
secretly serving Mesto his Soul could
have previously been kept in that brooch
that would be her husband Ralph that she
won't shut up about the one who shares
an anniversary with her that's a same
date as the Salem witch trials and that
maybe now that Mesto has taken human
form she just feels lost without him and
the closing shot shows us Wanda's eyes
as a Scarlet glow Fades you can almost
make out the shape of a person in that
red glow especially in noticeable on the
right eye again I don't really think
Wanda is doing this alone some other
entity is in the shadows enabling her
the true source of her Madness in the
West Coast Avengers run that Wanda
vision seems partly based on Agatha
gaslights Wanda into thinking she has
kids who are actually pieces of
mephisto's Soul as Petro called them
last episode unleash hell demon spawn
demon spawn notice that Wanda pops pills
and what does Agnes do for her when she
arrives bruise her tea I'm assuming some
herbal tea herb hold on herb she even
makes an herb out of herb and why is she
doing this well the drug rugging keeps
Wanda in the fantasy so that Agatha can
consume the life force of her children
now Did Agnes actually gobble up these
kids like the witch and the Hansel and
grle story no no no they're probably
locked up somewhere or part of some kind
of ritual somewhere deep in that dungeon
as they are being what reassumed into
misto maybe drained of their energy but
like House of M I think this is all
going to end with Wanda not being able
to hold on to these kids look folks I'm
not going to try to fool you Agatha is
clearly the villain of the show Westview
is her operation but she's got
associations with witchcraft with dark
magic and there's still a very good
chance she has a silent partner that we
haven't met yet and all signs are
pointing to Mesto not just the devil in
the details not just demon spawn a Paul
betney interview was released this week
suggesting there is still an unseen
major Cameo popping up there is one
character that has not been revealed and
it is very exciting it's an actor that
I've longed to work with all of my life
and in the same interview Paul betney
seemed really koi about Mesto in
particular I can't speak to right now
because I'm worried about getting uh
fired so as great as this Agatha reveal
is I think most of us did see it coming
so there is probably one deeper mystery
left in the shadows the darkest Is Yet
To Come yeah Ghost Rider will be coming
to the
MCU um I don't think in W Vision I think
it's way too soon to bring in ghost he
just rides in on that
motorcycle I would atte that oh God it
would be too wild the only way it would
make sense Jessica is if this ends with
some Pandora's box of every Marvel demon
just like jumping out like another
endgame portals moment but instead it's
just all the from hell I would
oh that would be so sick if it was just
like all the like Ghost Rider type like
demons coming out that'd be kind of sick
I'd be okay I'd be into that I'd be into
that but this is why I want Mesto cuz
Mesto is the one who gives Ghost Rider
his Hellfire right right so like if you
get misto in there a lot of fun can
real misto would bring the fun misto
would bring more people which is fun
nightmare would just bring the
chaoticness of nightmare which is fun to
me I think which we wouldn't get into it
but I am obsessed with Club fear so I
was like if this Mo like he's basically
Oogie Boogie from The Powerpuff Girls
and just imagine like like him coming in
and it'd be so fun but I am like misto
would bring more characters that would
be greater for the MCU whereas nightmare
would just bring his cool chaotic energy
which Freddy Kruger's great and all but
like I want to see more demons all right
let's take another question I mean Mesto
first appeared as a fly in the comics
that could have something to do with it
but I'm I don't want to feed into Eric's
theories anymore that I have why
not they said I have to because you're
putting them in a choke cold feed my
theories I hope he's watching this now
and sees that you're
ridiculous I don't think that fly was
misto I think that fly was a reference
to like oh this is a witch who has like
all kinds of weird animals in including
cicas and I think it was the Silence of
the Lambs thing personally uh it
definitely wasn't a it was it was too
big to be a fly that's why I was like
this is a cicada um this is a sucker
cicada too big for it's also very loud
it's too it's too loud for a fly but
just loud enough for a cicada if you
guys know cicas they're annoying and I
hate them um
and I hate them well andas do a thing
they stay cocooned what they have like
17 years where they don't like they just
stay asleep and then they have a short
reproduction cycle so that could be like
kind of like how Agnes stays like
dormant dormant dormant kind of like the
way Pennywise and in it stay dant for 27
years creep she's just a monster that
comes back every spring after 10 years
um but yeah no I think that'd be cool
though and also you don't have to feed
into Vas is
weird yeah I'll find I'll find my feed I
I'm a a natural Grazer of theories I
don't need to be hand fed my theory my I
like that they ended it with like I I
have to or else it'll kill me that was
you no it wasn't literally me just my
eyes and ears a crystalum possession
necromancy was a non-starter since your
real brother's body is on another
continent so earlier this week Kevin FY
said Evan Peter's casting was to use his
words just another way that certain
people were messing around with Wanda
yeah I'm sure the fox Quicksilver fans
will accept that it's also interesting
how feige said certain people another
hint that AGA might not be working alone
agav seems to have lost someone she
loves and she's frustrated that she can
only do basic spells like animal
transmutation while Wanda just has this
innate power that she didn't really earn
and who would Agatha love well as a
witch of Salem folks read up on your
history it's not reaching to assume This
Witch would claim her spouse to be the
devil yeah folks I'm going down with the
ship right or wrong because it's the
best evidence we got here's my closing
argument Agatha's husband Ralph is Mesto
AKA Senor scratchy the rabbit a
reference to Old Scratch a nickname for
the devil this rabbit is the best Agatha
could do to bring him back using spells
from the darkhold this is the rabbit
remember she bragged as having star
potential Senor scratchy has got real
star quality don't you think it was his
demonic protection that allowed Agatha
to overthrow the coven but doing that
broke his soul because Agatha was not
the Scarlet Witch that he thought she
was she did not get the crown and as in
the West Coast Avengers Comics this
series is now definitely based on
evidence by white Vision mephisto's soul
is broken in those Comics Agatha helps
him manipulate Wanda using pieces of his
soul to create Billy and Tommy later
shown to be hand puppets of mephisto's
Minion and now Agatha puppets these boys
like marionettes on strings and notice
as she does this her fingers turn black
suggesting that these Illusions are
actually draining some of her life force
these kids were just called demon spawn
and that was not long after the devil's
in the details Bev that's not the only
place he is what does AGA want she wants
the Nexus powers of the Scarlet Witch
she was unable to get them from her
mother and she wants them now from Wanda
so that she can repair M Fisto's soul
and together they can rule the
Multiverse a power that the rest of her
coven thought no one should harness I
know I know it seems like the bety Cameo
te's might have been just him trolling
us but uh-uh I am going to place my bets
on Mesto showing up in the finale he's
going to be played by an actor so
beloved no one's going to care that he's
been off screen All Season or how weird
it is that the MCU has Satan in it now
you just reminded us that this is based
on the west coast Avenger run and I
think that's significant Jessica because
white Vision firmly locks us into West
Coast Avengers I mean they've referenced
all kinds of different Comics they've
referenced the Tom King Comics uh it
seems like they've done a bit of a House
of M but the West Coast Avengers run the
most famous thing from that is this
whole thing with Mesto Agatha Tommy and
Billy so uh that all goes down while
vision is white vision and look people
are going to hate me for sticking on
this Mesto train but I feel owe it I owe
it to all of you I have to go down with
the ship if this is not the case
I'll take the L um keep playing the that
ending moment there Jessica she's
holding those two boys tethering them
around their
necks with hand in hand is that not
similar to a marionette the way those
two boys were puppeted by Master
pandemonium in the comics I get it it is
zoom in on Eric's face by the
ticktockers of the moment Eric realized
he was wrong yeah yeah yeah I get it
also like she was she's also Al like a
powerful witch I I don't know if we're
going to get into this later or we
probably will but her magic differing
from Wanda's magic and how her magic is
slightly the same as Doctor Strange's
magic fight me um but fight me um but I
just think she and also the she knows
the kids aren't real so I think she was
like I'm just going to choke these kids
with some power I'm going to choke these
kids with some magic I get where you're
coming from thing if she knows the kids
aren't real why it's that's a
performative thing that she's trying to
manipulate Wanda's feelings right now
are imagin and she is put a of them why
would do that you know and all these
other Clues you've gotten unleash hell
demon spawn you know it's all there for
people are like oh this episode makes it
seem less like misto I'm like honestly I
feel like we're exactly where we were
the past couple episodes I was too
attached to the fact that she turned a
cicada into a bird and then thre the
bird into the rabbit's mouth and I was
like yeah there's something weird with
this rabbit and we are not the Rabbit
doesn't just Birds rabbit rabbits are
herbivores herbivores
herbivores Jessica can't pronounce her
right that's the thing that rabbit guys
we still have a lot of Myster there with
what that rabbit is who is Ralph like
that's why I think there could be some
other cameo coming maybe it's I think
the rabbit is something I think we go
back to the rabbit tangent cuz I think
the rabbit may be something because
rabbits don't just eat birds but also
even if the rabbit was just like like oh
yeah if someone was to PL like throw it
over their head and be just like it's
yeah it's a demon rabbit like of course
he eats bird I'd be like but it ate a
bird like it's not it's not just a demon
rabbit those are just come lying around
it's it's it's a misto no I think um I
mean okay actually we got to talk more
about Wanda after the break real quick
um but I'll just say right now if you're
still on the misto train no shame choo
choo I'll be conducting this train right
off a cliff I don't get one way yeah one
way ticket off a cliff yeah I have to I
I just think the evidence is still there
it's as much there as it was last week
it's still pretty weak evidence I'd say
but it's enough it's enough there and
there's still enough out of an out I
respect you because if it turns out to
be Mesto I'd be like damn I even turned
away from it like I was even like I
don't think it's Mesto anymore you fair
weather misto fans you cowards ready to
leave one Station 2 soon before we get
to the gates of hell we're so close why
are you backing out now vas has just
gone insane I totally have I've lost
I've been insane I've been insane since
the first trailer for this show I'm like
oh there's going to be a devil in this
like okay I think the rabbits just going
to be Ralph at the very least like that
rabbit's going to be called ral's going
to be something else we still don't know
who the missing person is we still we
don't we don't and I think that's kind
of the big huh the big question mark
remaining uh what is this rabbit is it
Ralph and is Ralph nightmare or Mesto or
Chon or one of these other demonic
entities or is it some new thing that
Marvel Cinematic uh universe is going to
introduce I could totally be wrong about
misto I understand uh but I have to go
down with the ship so I want to make a
final argument uh for why I think misto
might still show up because the last
okay go ahead go ahead go ahead give him
your platform we start this episode with
a sale which trial but a different which
trial which on which right so in the
language of this people are saying oh
they kind of Sid stepped uh some of the
dark uh satanic elements to appease
China no go check out me and uh mt's um
big question episode they could totally
put in all kinds of dark Superstition
stuff in there they don't care about
China Disney plus is not in China and
when it is they can simply remove this
title from it and not care they can
remove this episode they can edit
episodes uh so that it isn't about
satanic stuff we talked about this
rabbit I just want to focus for a second
on the fact that they're speaking in
Latin and I think that's a deliberate
choice because Latin is the association
of like ancient spells in our world uh
because it is a lot of this magic is
done in defiance of the Roman Catholic
Church uh it has a Christian origin the
fact that they're saying they could say
any kind of weird madeup language that
moment they deliberately had them say
Latin which I think gives a kind of
Christian overtone to what their dark
magic is now this rabbit it's still we
don't know this rabbit is g to be
something he's and they call him seor
scratchy now if he's not her son
Nicholas scratch were back to the
argument that he could be Old Scratch
she said in episode two Sor scratch has
got real star quality don't you think uh
he is a carnivore which rabbits are not
he said something to her
this rabbit could and he was right next
to the open darkh hold on the table
there's something with this rabbit we
know that this is tied to the West Coast
Aventure story line and sure they're
going to leave out plenty of elements
from the West Coast adventure story line
they're only adapting pieces of it but
the most important thing and this isn't
just like what were the Nerds are
pulling up some obscure comic issue and
making a case for it every time in the
past when uh Elizabeth Olsen has done uh
a press for who the Scarlet Witch
character is she's like I'm going go
back and explain who uh Scarlet Witch is
in the comics for all you Marvel fans
she brings up this whole storyline of
her kids being pieces of mephisto's soul
that is so important to Scarlet Witch's
Journey uh and that sets up House of M
uh it like misto is G an important
character in the MCU in so many ways uh
or in the Marvel Comics in so many ways
and they said unleash hell demon spawn
you know there all these clues in there
and these aren't just throwaway visual
Clues like the Grim Reaper helmet and
the animated intro these are lines that
characters say and they're lines that
the writers have to know the meaning of
when they put it in there and then
finally I you know when she has these
tethers around these kids throats like
if she knows they aren't real why is she
so uh worried about threatening them if
not for it being a show a marionette
show a puppet show and it evokes that
moment of P Master Pandemonium puppeting
the kids with his hands I think these
kids could be pieces of misto Soul if
they're going to call him
explicitly in the episode it's one thing
maybe it'll be implicit just something
we could interpret from it but all the
evidence is there that they are
definitely being inspired by that moment
of Mesto using fragments of his soul to
manifest children that are tricks uh to
manipulate Wanda it's all there uh how
far they want to go to spell out that
this rabbit or that there's someone in
the shadows but Ralph there's a missing
person we don't know what this rabbit is
he's something and it's going to get
revealed in the final episode Billy and
Tommy like many in the Scarlet Witch and
vision series the story is never truly
coherent or linear with how these people
get brought into the world and with
Billy and Tommy are so freaking weird
like they start out as pieces of misto
Soul like tricks but then like Mesto uh
is like attacked so he can't ever like
fully stay in his full form until later
and then uh the kids get brought back
into the universe as mutants who at
first we don't really know that they are
the same kids uh as who were Scarlet
Witch's kids but then they are later uh
back defined as like oh those were the
same kids and their mutant and that's
why Wiccan uh sorcery is like Wanda's
sorcery and uh yeah so I I don't think
it's going to be the same actors I think
these kids are a bit young um but I
think they're going to cast some bigger
name actors to play them in a future
Young Avengers team up in on Disney plus
MCU yeah and can't wait to see it can't
wait to see it now the question is is
just like how how uh what does real mean
in the purposes of the hex um because we
know that uh Vision in the hex was just
Wanda's magic bringing him back she did
not steal Visions corpse uh and we know
that it looks like Petro is something
similar that Agatha did that she just
used magic to Incarnate him you know uh
and she puppets him around so these kids
look like they're sort of the same thing
um so are they going to be pieces of
mistos soul I think so I think unleash
held demon spawn means that like next
week it's going to be implied that
they're pieces of a demon soul demon B
yeah you really hung up on that un the
demon SP I have a duty to be hung up on
it it it just opens so many more doors
which isn't a problem but it opens so
many more questions if their souls go
into other things it's like
so so Vision does have a soul and she
created it she's God yeah yeah yeah so
but I think Vision so many things but
what vision's soul was was already
something a bit artificial to begin with
it was the mindstone AI that was like
you know bleeding through the rest of
his vibranium body and that had a
humanistic element to it because the
mindstone has some sort of cosmic
intelligence to it and that mixed with
all the other factors um sorcery and a
way to to make Vision have a quote
unquote Soul so I think W is capable
through her mindstone d Powers at this
point it's not wi mindstone derived it's
mindstone empowered Powers Amplified
Powers uh was able to Incarnate this
version of vision soul but it seems to
be tied to her own memories right he's
he's not fully there with all of
vision's memories it's not yeah yeah so
I think she can like bring up that soul
but I think these boys as pieces of
misto soul I don't think they're true
souls in the way that like herb has a
soul or you know Mrs Hart has a soul
these other West viiew people have a
soul
um so we're back to now acknowledging
maesto is in this he has to be in this
world which you were already on he
doesn't have to I just think already on
board yeah well I do think the kids are
going somewhere so they have to be
attached Tang tangentially or whatever
to mist or
someone yeah okay so when Agatha said
she had like the Bas of protection spell
runes on her wall did you see that there
was one that was an M cuz I know Eric
like this could really just beat into
the Mesto train like I'm on that train
Dam you guys are feeding his misto
needes y'all just giving it to him now
you guys just want him to be you guys
are cheering him on to be
wrong uh it did look kind of like an m
one looked like a crop circle a little
bit I think they were trying to make it
look like some kind of uh old language
some old runes um to me it didn't look
so much like an m just like oh it has
like three downward kind of things
swooshes swopes but uh if if misto is in
this I don't think we'll be able to go
back to that Rune and be like aha that's
that's what it was that was the clue
that told us that it was misto I think
he's going to come out of the darkhold
if he is in this or he's gonna that
rabbit's going to turn into a famous
actor that Paul betney has always wanted
to work with who's not himself Paul
betney he just also playing Paul betney
is literally playing this is the Eddie
Murphy he's playing every character he's
been doing a great Elizabeth Olsen
impression in this all yeah he's so
talented Agatha explicitly said the
Scarlet Witch's Powers surpass those of
even the sorcerer Supreme and she warned
Wanda about what she had Unleashed
question mark question mark now I know
what you are going to say so boss where
was misto you idiot I know I really got
carried away on that Mesto train didn't
I I thought I was Pizza Time Peter and I
could stop it before it derailed but
really I was Marty McFly trying to blast
the F out of there as the train crash
behind me into a
ravine except I'm still on that train
choo choo let me tell you the fire down
here feels so warm why am I still in the
train well not only did a page of that
dark hold appear to show another dark
creepy figure on the left side of the
book when Agatha was looking through it
not only did a red light lens flare
flash in the closing frame to look like
red eyes Beyond Wanda and not only does
a myoy figure appear in that stained
glass in the Loki trailer but those boys
crying for help it is still possible
these kids could be pieces of misto Soul
folks demon spawn but a question not
answered in W division a question
perhaps going to be answered in
Multiverse of Madness but I know I'm
sounding crazy so let me back up and try
to explain how this insane Mesto train
got started one division's director Matt
shakman in an interview with
comicbook.com this week signal to fans
that they should brace themselves for
finale reveals that might not live up to
their theories I hope people find it um
both surprising but inevitable you know
the idea I hate stories that pivot you
know 180 at the last minute and you're
like what have I been watching this
whole time you know Agatha Christie
novels where the murderer of someone you
just met Pops in you're like come on why
did I read this whole thing but you
could totally argue that like a great
Agatha Christie mystery Clues were laid
out consistently throughout the episodes
pointing to misto and that rather than
someone we just met he didn't feel like
a presence that was with us from the
beginning all along but whole time the
Mesto train really left the station back
in August 2019 a month after Kevin feige
introduced W Vision at Comic-Con and now
kathern Han was announced at d23 to be
playing a quote nosy neighbor and
immediately fans begin to speculate that
that could mean the witch Agatha
Harkness arguably the most important
female relationship Wanda maximoff has
in the comics and Agatha being part of w
Vision meant a very strong possibility
that Marvel's devil misto might show up
as well one of the most famous Wanda
Envision storylines was the West Coast
Avengers run in the late 80s in which
Wanda's children Billy and Tommy are
revealed to be pieces of memphisto soul
in a plot in which Agatha brainwashes
this memory from Wanda's mind and this
wasn't just some obscure comic book
issue that no one ever read it's a
critical turning point in Wanda's
Journey it's so crucial that Elizabeth
olssen even cited this in a Scarlet
Witch historical summary WR as civil war
came out back in May 2016 Scarlet Witch
had her very own Marvel Immaculate
Conception she used magic to make
herself pregnant and gave birth to twin
boys the vision had his memory wiped he
and Scarlet got a divorce and the twins
turned out to be shards of the demon
mefisto almost 5 years ago folks W
maximov herself pretty much described
the plot of w Division and add that to
the fact that M festo's name showed up
as an Easter egg in the first Avengers
film in 2012 and the way thanos's minion
ebony ma directly quoted Mesto from The
Infinity Gauntlet comics my humble
personage bows before your grandar and
it is clear that Marvel Studios at least
has had Mesto on the brain for several
years but then that Mesto train hit that
first speed boost in February 2020 when
w division's first promo footage
revealed this series would indeed
introduce her sons Billy and Tommy and
then another speed boost in October 2020
when kathern hans's character was named
Agnes in a trailer a name we correctly
ided as a crossy amalgamation of Agatha
Harkness and so in January when w
division premiered many of us were
primed to be on a very sharp lookout for
Mesto or really anything that moves so
that we could point to it and scream
aesto and right out of the gate in
episode one Agnes mentioned her
off-screen husband Ralph the only way
Ralph would remember our anniversary as
if there was a beer named June 2nd June
2nd was the date the Salem Witch Trials
began in 1692 and then boom look at this
episode 8 confirmed Agatha as a Salem
witch getting roasted by her own coven
one year later in 16 1993 Agnes also
says the devil's in the details Bev
that's not the only place he is yeah
what does that mean like if Agnes was
referring to doy or her booze nothing
came out of those which left this as a
pretty solid misto clue and then Midway
through the season Paul betney was asked
about Mesto and played Super koi about
it in the interview I can't speak to
right now because I'm worried about
getting uh fired then in episode 6 fetro
says unleash hell demon spawn haha after
devil in the details this was our
biggest clue yet that the boys Billy and
Tommy could actually be piece of Spawn
from the demon Mesto and then episode 7
steered hard into witchcraft by
revealing it was Agatha all along with
her rabbit incapable of being scanned by
telepath Billy Agatha revealed she
hijacked West View using dark magic from
that evil spell book The demonic
darkhold from a dungeon covered in
satanic imagery including a horned Ram's
Head On The Wall episode 8 opens with a
fullon Salem witch trial now
historically The Witches of Salem were
persecuted for suspected romantic
affiliations with the devil witches
consider themselves to be lovers and
wives of Satan these witches also cast
spells in the language of
Latin mon not tying their witchcraft to
Christian cultural influences the same
fire and brimstone imagery that Marvel
based Mesto on and now in the episode A
lot of the things we thought could have
been Clues were actually pointing in
other directions like Agnes's offscreen
husband Ralph ended up being a
borderline insulting rug Poole making
Evan Peters fetro and aspiring actor
named Ralph boner huh cannot wait to see
what the fox Quicksilver fans do with
that one Senor scratchy nowhere to be
found but still those boys the boys
perhaps still demon spawn because of
their Cries From the darkhold something
with a fiery orange glow emanating off
of it also earlier in the episode Wanda
said thanks for choosing me to be your
mom now yes I got way too trigger happy
thinking Mesto could appear in Wanda
Vision obviously this is not a show
about Mesto it was a show about Wanda
and Scrolls but darker forces remain out
there the table is set and I am still
leaving the chair open for the devil
just either in Loki or Multiverse of
Madness no regrets but you are right in
terms of our theorizing yeah I mean we
start to connect the dots in ways that
the writers did not intend us to connect
uh that is on us but it's also like you
know it's it's kind of fun to do that
week to week and just uh speculate and
as long as at the end of it which we
don't do this we don't be like that's it
I'm canceling Disney Plus subscription
we I'm happy to take whatever ending
they're going to give us um but
recognize that there is a responsibility
by the director and the writer to
understand how an audience is going to
interpret this and when your core
audience is are people who love Marvel
films and you put in Evan Peters in this
how do you think think they're going to
react with the probability Factor it
might make S it might make more sense
that like the major villain if it is
Maisto if it shows up in Dr Strange
second movie and he's like I can't
defeat this person by myself I need
Scarlet Witch I don't need Wanda Maxim
off I need Scarlet Witch so that could
be like he's like probability like he
sees all the different routes it could
take and be like I can only defeat this
thing if you're Scarlet Witch not if
you're yeah he needs not someone who can
just do like uh red Wiggly l but he
needs a Scarlet witch who has absorbed
all of Agatha's collected magic and then
he would know that she read the book and
not to shame doctor strange but he had
to do all that stuff in his sleep she's
consciously walking around drinking tea
and doing a bunch of stuff so he
probably is like I know how strong you
are like I'm aware of it you read the
book um though it's evil you read the
book so that definitely could be
probability that could absolutely happen
wizard the did Wanda unleash there's two
ways this could go in my book so one she
could have just Unleashed what we said
what I said earlier I think we both
agree uh all the portals like just
releasing like different portals around
the globe or universe that are like the
um releasing the Multiverse so different
dimensions ultimately B she if she was a
Wonder gor M okay so what if she was at
that mountain right what if she had to
be closer to that mountain because
that's where the book came came from
because of the demon I'm not going to
say the Demon's name after you tweeted
about the Demon's name I'm too afraid to
say the Demon's name you say it three
times he'll appear ch
ch I can't say his name I don't want
Kath CH ton Taco Town USA I was like I
don't want to say it cuz I know I'm GNA
butcher it but so my someone responded
in a great way that it's based on cthulu
and human uh vocal cords and mouths
cannot pronounce it otherwise we would
go insane if we did pronounce it
correctly okay so I can't pronounce it
correctly cuz I'm not insane and watch
me pronounce it correctly but what if
she Unleashed that the demon or she
unleashes Maisto so I'm like there I
think it's one of the one of the two she
either un Unleashed a demon or she
Unleashed just portals over the world
releasing different people from
different dimensions cuz that would be
reason for why we're going to get Doc O
in Spider-Man far no way home right wasz
it the happened to the
twins yeah so I think these twins never
existed to begin with that's my theory I
think these twins were always a piece of
demonic magic that uh was used to trick
Wanda through outside forces from the
dark hold because Wanda at the end says
thank you for letting me be thank you
for choosing me to be your mom
Wanda kind of created but W Wanda Vision
obviously didn't conceive these kids
normally right it's implied that they
fooled around but vision's a robot he
can't conceive children Wanda we didn't
see Wanda create these kids the way she
created Vision so I think these kids
were tricks that came from and they
weren't fully fleshed out characters
right they were kind of these ideal
versions and I think for the purposes of
this in the hex they were sweet boys who
wanted Wanda's help or wanted to help
Wanda in their dad Vision but I think
their voices screaming from the dark
hold at the end I think that was the
voice of what whatever demon you want to
be in the MC next I think there I think
they the voice that was the voice of
Mesto in that moment I could see that I
could see that I I could see the the
ending part I really have a hard time
believing that those kids were like they
they were there but they weren't re they
were there as much as Vision was there
you know not as much as Vision was there
I think uh they were like cuz they
weren't created by her magic you know
they were pulled through some other
means do you think not that's this ties
in with our next what w to the you did
this on purp I think I think these boys
are demon spawn uh and I think that was
just they are going to eventually bring
in this thing of Mesto has pieces of his
soul that are that like at some point
later in the future W is going to be
like then what were my sons and dror
strange is GNA be like sit down honey
there's Demon's demon and he keeps doing
that you're not the only one he's done
this to he does it to a lot of people
but he makes people think they have kids
and they're that way we're not actually
seeing the process of these kids being
evaporated and sucked into the skin of a
demon that makes sense cuz we didn't
even see them like die I think we might
still see that I mean these two actors
one of these actors just tweeted me it
was so cool uh I was so flattered yeah
uh uh Julian hilard uh who played Billy
uh was so sweet and he said I'm sorry I
wasn't Mesto all along but I'm like not
a clue not a clue he was just being nice
oh my God a little baby yeah but he was
like uh yeah I think these kids might be
in Multiverse of Madness and that whole
story could get shown there well this is
the thing that's kind of piss me off
about the casting cuz I was like looking
at the casting for Doctor Strange too
and I was like how many of these people
are just going to be like
flashbacks I'd hope they wouldn't do
that but I was like watch them be
flashbacks for Wanda and that's why
they're like credited as cast in the
movies and I'm going to be like I'm
going to be see I think the kids is how
Wanda gets lured into the Multiverse of
Manda she's going to go on a chase to
try to find these kids in different
realities once she finds them they're
going to be a snare and misto is going
to rope her in real talk look real talk
speculative talk we'll see I've been
wrong before folks I'll be wrong again
when will misto appear chess do you
think it'll be Loki Multiverse manness
moonnight midnight Suns blade Ghost
Rider never the never I think it will I
pitch Doctor Strange too I think it
would but what is the timeline again you
tell me this every time but the timeline
of when the movies are coming out so we
have we finished ju division we have uh
Falcon winner soldier Falcon winner
soldier home and then we have uh Black
Widow still tely scheduled for May but
we have uh Loki in June yes Loki then we
have what if and then we have Hawkeye
and Miss Marvel coming in the fall uh we
have uh shangi over the summer in July
we have eternals coming in nov damn we
got a full thing before we get and then
we have Spider-Man no way home coming in
December and then in January of 2022 we
could be seeing moonight and or She-Hulk
around that time um but in March will be
Multiverse of Madness followed by Thor
love and thunder in May well hopefully
they push it up now at first I was like
I don't think they're going to push it
up but now I'm like okay I think they
need to push it up so my theory that
Mista will show up and it makes more
sense I think it would still make sense
even if it's uh way far away and cuz I
mean whatever Wanda's problem is Will
manifest in mult ver of Madness and I
think we can have patience until then
they wouldn't make him the like big
villain right I think the big villain
will be like Wanda because like I'm not
saying it has to be the equivalent to
Thanos I'm just saying like you got to
for me as a fan you have to give me
something bigger than that so what's
bigger than than a member of your own
team that is
Unstoppable and I've always thought we
don't necessarily need a villain uh in
this uh like a a you know capital V
villain we could a relationship between
doct strange and wand as kind of a a
doctor a a doctor a Healer and a patient
and it's just kind of like this badass
therapy scene where they're like in a
wizard duel the whole time but he's
really just trying to heal her and help
her and she doesn't want to be helped so
it's not like a story about like Pixar's
old rules uh was that they weren't going
to have any obvious villains to the plot
uh so like if you go back to Toy Story
Sid is kind of a villain but he's not
like the structural
Wy is kind of the Anton to that story
you know not he's kind of a jerk but
then he learns to change and to accept
newcomers um and I think good stories do
that uh and Marvel is kind of evolving
to the point to where they don't need a
villain in every story true so this is
just one where they're like trying to
like help her trying to break it down
and she's just not like either listening
or just like I don't know how that nice
right another so I think we might get a
glimpse of Loki in uh get a glimpse of
of misto Andi um but I think uh if he
does show up it's going to be in
Multiverse of Madness if not there it's
going to be sometime away in the future
uh when Ghost Rider needs to show up
because misto is part of Ghost Rider
origin yeah if it shows up in Loki I
don't think it's going to be a
heavy-handed thing I think it's more so
we're going to get a little bit of teas
yeah a little bit we're going to get a
little taste a little TST it has to be
him because a how are you going to do
Ghost Rider I know you did w division
without like I guess
Magneto yet but like Ghost Rider you
kind of have to bring misto in so yeah I
mean w already exists in the MCU so they
were just able to kind of reframe some
of the story we already saw but yeah
Ghost Rider uh if you introduce some
cold turkey yeah you're going to need a
real hot turkey down below to give that
you're going have to bring Nicholas Cage
with you oh yes deadline is now
reporting that our dark lord and savior
May indeed appear in the MCU Iron Heart
series coming to Disney plus next year
play by Baron Cohen I thought we saw the
devil in Borat 2 now I was hesitant
discussing this before since it was just
a rumor only buzzed about from not
always reliable Anonymous scoopers
online but now very legitimate news
source deadline has reported quote a
source close to the production confirmed
to deadline that there has been talk on
the set about Cohen being part of Iron
Heart likely playing Mesto Reps for
Marvel and Cohen have refused to comment
on any Cohen involvement in iron heart
or the larger MCU now if you're deadline
you do not run with that unless there is
something there and I think signs are
pointing to mephisto's debut I mean sure
I have always been an Adventist seen
Mesto signs importance ever since 2020
and yes I like many of you was pretty
surprised that a show like iron har
would be the one to introduce misto kind
of feels like saying the next Fast and
Furious movie would introduce Santa
Claus I guess the way that franchise is
heightening possible but the more you
look into iron har and everything Marvel
Studios has been teasing about it the
Fisto actually starts to make a lot more
sense in the show so iron har will be a
six episode series coming to Disney Plus
in 2023 starring Dominque Thor as R
Williams an MIT Engineering student from
Chicago who builds armor in the style of
Iron Man we will first meet her in Black
Panther wakand forever where charot
footage has shown her in at least two
versions of her armor a Mark 1 suit
during a car chase and then later in
wakanda a mark 2 suit she works
alongside shuri in the wakandan lab
hammers out a heart- shape and vibranium
she appears alongside Queen Ronda during
an attack from Neymar and blasts off
from wakanda in Mark 2 armor with Tony
Stars Mark 50 style rocket boosters and
an internal heads up display other
promos have given us different looks at
her armor the villain of this Iron Heart
series will be Anthony Ramos as Parker
Robins aka the hood a criminal known for
wielding guns that fire bullets with
mystical properties in the comics Robins
gets his mystical powers from a demon
that is later revealed to be Damu but
reportedly in this series Damu whom we
saw in the 2016 Doctor Strange film and
doesn't really have a human Avatar he's
mostly just a big purple face in the
dark dimension it sounds like Damu is
instead being swapped out with mytho a
demon who's known to take many human
forms now I saw the Iron Heart trailer
at d23 and misto did not show up in itef
summary we see Jim rash's MIT liaison
from Captain America Civil War
reprimanding Riri for one of her
experiments blowing up he says Miss
Williams you are not the first genius at
M and Riri says I'm an engineer the best
way to know things is to take it apart
and put it back together then you can
see what it's made of what I'm doing
that's iconic Parker Robin says anyone
who's ever accomplished anything iconic
in life has had to do some questionable
things to get it done what will you do
Riri and Riri says I'm going to build
something like him referring to Iron Man
but then she adds but you know better
really it was the panel with Anthony
Ramos and executive producer Ryan
cougler and Kevin feige that hinted at
what Parker Robins might have meant by
questionable because they pitched this
show as a conflict between technology
and dark magic dark magic that might
have been unlocked through a deal with
the devil on the stage Anthony Ramos was
particularly foot and mouth in a way
that no other presenter was that day
that I saw this guy was definitely
scared of saying the wrong thing Parker
it's a it's it's a deep deep dive into a
dark place he goes into unfortunately
but but I think on the inside Parker
believes truly that he's he's doing good
and has a love for his crew and he has a
love for his people I don't want to get
I'm I'm over here trying to dance around
the plot like this cuz I can't give
y'all the Beats thank you for coming
here Anthony it's amazing no more he's
dancing too close but what's great is if
you know the character from the comics
he deals in the dark arts he deals in
Magic and when I was sitting there
listening to Ramos and feige I thought
what are they dancing around we saw what
this guy's deal is in the footage but
now based on these reports of Sasha
Baron Coen as mytho in retrospect it
really does seem like fige was warning
Ramos about dancing too close with the
devil as if right before they walked out
on stage Figi said do not say Mesto we
got to remind you all of the recent
hints to the guy in Thor love and
thunder in omnipotent City Zeus
referenced Satan in the background if
you listen closely so now we got to
announce the winner of the most human
Souls sacrificed in the name of a God
these Gods aren't going to help but that
Thunderball I think that might be a VI J
right and then of course in episode four
of shok we saw Madison with two ends and
a why but now where you think being sent
to a hell Dimension with skulls on
spikes and lava caverns and Madison
returning with a bloody human heart from
a demon goat named Jake in the closing
credits art we saw Jake with a name tag
which I'll try not to take as a personal
dick these light-hearted knots misto do
line up with a casting of a comedic
actor in this role though Sasha Baron
Cohen has rang getting a WS Buzz for his
betrayal of Abby Hoffman in the trial of
Chicago 7 the truth is that misto can
lurk anywhere regardless of the the tone
of the title as the devil can hide
behind Any Corner in any Shadow with a
tempting deal for any hero we say not
today Satan because Satan can drop by
any day but I think there's a secret
double meaning in the title iron heart
when you look at misto as a dealer in
human hearts and claiming Souls Riri as
a technologist has a heart of iron she's
uniquely immune to the seductions of a
devil promising Supernatural power
because fore an engineer like her power
comes from a soldering iron it's a lot
like when Loki tried to use his scepter
to turn Tony Stark's heart even
this usually works well performance
issues you know Tony's Iron Heart saved
him in that moment the deadline report
suggested Sasha Baron Co misto could be
introduced in ironheart so that he would
then appear in other MCU titles beyond
that Agatha coven of chaos seems like a
likely option AGA was a Salem witch in
1693 and historically she and other
witches during that era did consider
themselves lovers and wives of Satan and
in the comics W division was based on
AGA was a servant of misto and coming
out of that series there is so much more
to the origin of of the dark hold how it
got in the hands of that coven and from
the prologue of werewolf by night we got
a lot of questions about the backstory
of Supernatural lore in the MCU and now
that blade is being delayed a year with
a page one rewrite Mesto might be part
of those plans as well it could be
telling that the same week we learned
Marvel Studios is delaye blade is the
same week it gets out that they're
hiring Sasha Baron Cohen as misto this
could line up with blade meeting Dane
Whitman in the Eternal post credit scene
and set up a midnight Suns team up
consisting of Blade and black knight and
moonight and Elsa Bloodstone and Russell
and Ghost Rider God I hope that heart
that Madison had belonged to Johnny
Blaze oh wait Matt Jackman did further
humiliate me in the past week by
declaring for the 20th time that Mesto
was never part of the plan for w
Division I get it I'm Mr Mesto now and
anytime these interviews come out my
feed blows up I get it I I suppose I've
earned it Sasha Baron Cohen has been
confirmed to play Mesto in the Iron
Heart series whenever that comes out but
by now I think we know memphisto was
more of a feeling than an actual planned
cameo in W division we've learned a lot
of lessons like to think misto made us
better he definitely made a lot of
others worse follow me on Tik Tok
Instagram and Twitter at eaos follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
bye